[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's poppin hey guys hey I'm Jonah
I'm Jonah take a look at me look just
Joma 100,000 subscribers see I think you
guys should subscribe to my channel and
tackle it you should subscribe to tackle
it too hey by the way my name is John
Matlock I'm so cool I think I'm so funny
like everyone I'm depressed
I'm so depressed look look at the first
am
isn't that cool that's the only thing I
can do look I'm a data scientist see
look a poem has a data scientist I I
work in Silicon Valley okay what's
poppin at data science okay it's about
influence
it's about being influential and data
science is hard I'm the only person who
seems to know how to do data science now
my guys to take a look at this it's X a
mirror so you can see what's that noise
JAMA keep it down in there I thought I
told you to be quiet I'm trying to do a
vlog here my viewers demand quality and
quality is what they will get now where
was I how's my hair how's that look I
still look good
yeah well make sure that I still look
good so that I can do my vlogs here
where were we was that giving you let's
take a look at how I look in the mirror
pretty good though
like the way my hair looks yeah it's
nice and slick
[Music]
[Music]
okay Wow in a while I'm pretty rusty so
I'm gonna in my iPad I'm gonna look at
my notes okay all right so the first
thing that I want to say is that I'm
okay you know I'm not dead
a lot of you thought it was dead but I'm
definitely okay you know I'm alive and
yeah so you could let's now stop
worrying about me but I just want to say
thank you so so much for for everyone I
know in the last video you know I was
pretty depressed and stuff like that but
um I'm very happy now I'm very okay and
I was very surprised and how much you
guys cared and it was actually quite
touching and yeah like a lot of a lot of
people reached out to me even some
youtubers they all reached out to me to
see if I was okay so I'm super thankful
for that I really appreciate it and yeah
honestly it's one of the reasons why you
know I got better so that's that's
really cool of you guys so yeah so I
guess the title of this video was wide
that I stopped making videos well as you
know you know I had like a burnout so
that was definitely a factor and I
really needed to take some time to think
about you know what I really wanted to
do with my life my career with you know
the videos going forward and and yeah
and the reason why I had to think about
all that was because you know I was you
know because I had that catalyst and
that catalyst was you know that Bernal
and I catalyst really made me think
about you know my life in general and I
had to rethink some things and basically
it was kind of bad beginning because I
had a lot of negativity going on in my
life that I was kind of imposing on
myself some negativity and it was trying
to turn count like a vicious cycle I
don't know if you guys ever had this
thing where it's like oh you know for
example when you're sad about one thing
and because of that thing you're sad
about another thing and then it gets
worse and worse so I realized that and
and you know like I was very sad and I
had to fix myself before that spiral
goes into something worse and one of the
things I had to do was to take a break
and that means you know videos and other
stuff and I want to focus on my mental
health to remove a lot of these
stressors so I don't need to think about
them so I could kind of look at my life
at a more holistic view and that's
pretty much what I did so that's why I
did not make videos for a while because
not gonna lie that was kind of a
stressor at that time and and a lot of
you you know thanks for caring and you
wanted to know like how did I get up
this rut or like you know how did I not
be sad anymore
[Music]
yeah I mean there's no simple answer for
that I think you truly have to find out
for yourself some inner issues that you
have that you haven't solved yet
unfortunately for me it's quite personal
so I'm not really like super comfortable
sharing a few guys I know I'm a youtuber
but you know there are some limits and
but then also like while I was in that
state there's also a time aspect to it
like a lot of you guys told me that you
know a lot of people went through it and
they told me that it's not permanent and
and they're it's not permanent and
basically you know time does heal you
know and
yeah anyways yes so time does heal and
it so and yeah so yeah so it's it's not
permanent and time heals but you also
have to be kind of proactive into like
trying to figure out why you're in a rut
and stuff like that I mean for me at
least that's what I did
so because I had to be proactive and I
did a lot of things that to try to help
myself you know I went to therapy
I ran I went to the gym a lot you know
cuz you know I read internet articles on
my house how do I stop being sad and a
lot of the times that's what they tell
you to do so that all right you know so
I started doing all these things you
know I stopped making videos I kept
moving I tried to create better
relationships my friends and then be
more social always keep moving like it
was really hard in the beginning cuz you
really don't want to do that you really
don't want to do that by still did you
know because okay cuz I knew that it was
gonna be helpful in some ways or at
least my therapist told me you know and
I also watched a lot of anime I think
that helped you know I watched a lot of
anime you know in case you're curious
it's a I watched a hero academia food
Wars I also watched non anime stuff too
like Tara's house what else did i watch
well I watched psyche kay psyche Kay is
pretty like that was pretty funny
yeah lots of at I mean anyways um it was
and then after all that I kind of came
in
so then after all that I came to the
conclusion that there was like a
misalignment between my actions and my
values which was probably why it wasn't
that happy like I could talk about that
maybe sometimes in the future but
probably not now and yeah like well I
might talk about it a little bit in the
future but because now I kind of want to
talk about you know switch gears and
talk about something something more
positive
which is you know what's next what's
next with me well what's next with this
channel mostly I just want to say that a
startup series a lot of people are
waiting for a startup series I will
continue that I mean I do enjoy filming
it I love making it but it does take a
lot of time so I mean I still have a lot
of ideas in the back of my mind and I'm
very excited you know whenever I sleep
thinking about that so it's definitely
Stephanie coming hopefully and then I
asked for the other videos yeah like in
general there are probably gonna be less
videos coming out like I'll probably
still make videos but just less than
before because I don't want to make
videos just for the sake of making
videos you know I mean it's just it's
just less fun and then I'm pretty sure
like it's less entertaining also so I'm
so I'm just gonna you know I'll take my
time or in making videos and yeah
because you know I have a lot of other
things that I want to do right now that
I haven't done before so so I might yeah
so I just can't spend that much time on
videos so anyways okay what about what
about what's next in my life so I am
gonna continue what I'm doing now which
was like you know getting a lot of
social interactions
I'm just being more sociable with
developing my friendships and
relationships I think that's pretty
important for me right now and I'm
pretty damn happy doing it so I'll
probably prioritize that and then I'll
have also like other stuff going on in
my life some changed and stuff like that
but I decided to keep my life a little
bit more private you know just for - for
some boundaries and I think that is kind
of important if I we want to make this
sustainable so yeah yes anyways so
that's pretty much it so yeah thanks so
much again I really really appreciate it
every single comment I almost read
everyone
okay I lied but I read a lot of comments
you know from from the previous videos
and I was so grateful and yeah very
wholesome yeah I've really enjoyed it
and I really appreciate it and thank you
thank you guys so much again I'm not
very good at at making a saying these
things honestly I'm like an awkward guy
but I want to say is that you can stop
messaging like some me or my brother or
like my uke or everyone that's like
around me if I'm all care if I'm alive
so yeah thank you but yeah no need to
message them anymore
you know I am okay I'm actually very
very good I'm actually even happier than
before
and I should had a really really good
stay now so see ya it's pretty dope
anyways that's pretty much it so yeah
goochy goochy oh yeah I quit my job
[Music]